Last year, AP and I visited the Church
of the Holy Sephiler, considered by many
to be Christianity's holiest site
because it contains what is believed to
be the place of Jesus crucifixion as
well as the empty tomb. We were a little
annoyed because most of the building was
closed for renovations. We did get to go
inside the empty tomb, but they told me
I had to shut off my camera. Turns out
though that while they've been doing the
renovations, they've also been letting
archaeologists dig around a bit. And the
archaeologists are finding some
interesting things that help shed a
little light on a Bible mystery. During
the time of Jesus, the area where the
church of the holy sephiler now stands
was outside the wall of the old city of
Jerusalem. The place was an ancient rock
quarry. It was where workers would hue
rocks for building whatever they were
building. Eventually, the rock quarry
was shut down and people started using
the area to dig tombs. No mystery so
far. But the Gospel of John says that
Jesus tomb was in a garden. And a garden
doesn't sound at all like a rock quarry.
So, what's going on?
The Times of Israel reports, "Some 2,000
years ago, olive trees and grape vines
likely grew on the land where the Church
of the Holy Sephilar in Jerusalem stands
today. New archaeological excavations at
the site have revealed." The findings
mirror a description of the area
included in the Gospel of John. Now in
the place where he was crucified, there
was a garden, and in the garden a new
sephiler, wherein was never man yet
laid. There laid they Jesus, reads John
19:19 to20. Let's read the context in a
modern
translation. Later, Joseph of Arya asked
Pilate for the body of Jesus. Now,
Joseph was a disciple of Jesus, but
secretly because he feared the Jewish
leaders. With Pilate's permission, he
came and took the body away. He was
accompanied by Nicodemus, the man who
earlier had visited Jesus at night.
Nicodemus brought a mixture of myrr and
allows about 75 lbs. Taking Jesus' body,
the two of them wrapped it with the
spices in strips of linen. This was in
accordance with Jewish burial customs.
At the place where Jesus was crucified,
there was a garden. And in the garden, a
new tomb in which no one had ever been
laid because it was the Jewish day of
preparation. And since the tomb was
nearby, they laid Jesus there. So there
was a garden according to the Gospel of
John. And nearly 2,000 years later, the
claim gets confirmed by archaeology.
The presence of olive trees and grape
vines was identified through
archobotanical and pollen analysis on
samples retrieved from the excavations
under the floor of the ancient basilica.
From the archaeological context and
strata, it belongs to the pre-Christian
era. However, radiocarbon testing has
not yet been carried out. We know that
the area was already part of the city at
the time of Emperor Hadrien when the
Romans built Aelia Capalina said
professor Francesca Romana Stasola of
the Sapienza University of Rome
referring to the Roman city erected on
the ruins of Jerusalem in the first half
of the 2n century CE. However, at the
time of Jesus, the area was not part of
the city yet. Again, the tomb was
outside the wall of Jerusalem during the
time of Jesus. The Jews expanded the
wall to prepare for the first Jewish
Roman war. The Romans won the war and
leveled the place. According to
Christian tradition, the church of the
holy sephiler stands on the spot where
Jesus was crucified known as Calvary or
Golgatha and on its nearby tomb which
today is surmounted by an edicule built
in
1810. Stasola has been directing the
current excavations since they commenced
in 2022. According to Stasola, the
hidden layers beneath the church's
floor, similar to the pages of a book,
have offered an extraordinary chronicle
of the history of Jerusalem, starting
with the Iron Age, 1 1200 to 586 B.C.E.
"The church stands on a quarry, which
does not surprise us because a vast part
of the old city of Jerusalem stands on a
quarry," said Stasola. The quarry was
already active in the Iron Age. During
the excavation, we found pottery, lamps,
and other everyday objects dating back
to that period. As the quarry ceased to
be exploited, and before the church was
built, part of the area was used for
agriculture. People started growing
grapes and
olives. Low stone walls were erected and
the space between them was filled with
dirt, said Stasola. The archaeobotanical
findings have been especially
interesting for us in light of what is
mentioned in the Gospel of John whose
information is considered written or
collected by someone familiar with
Jerusalem at the time. The gospel
mentions a green area between the
cavalry and the tomb and we identified
these cultivated
fields. So there was an ancient rock
quarry. The rock quarry was eventually
abandoned. At some point, people hauled
dirt to the area to grow some crops. At
the time of Jesus, the former quarry was
also used as a burial site with several
tombs huneed in the rock as in other
Jerusalem areas. We need to imagine that
as the quarry was progressively
abandoned, tombs were carved at
different levels. Stasola said the area
therefore featured several burials from
that period. Constantine selected the
one that had been venerated as the tomb
where Jesus was buried and he excavated
around it in the area that corresponds
to the current rotunda isolating it from
the other burials. Several other tombs
are known as part of the holy sephiler
compound including one that Christian
tradition attributes to Joseph of
Arythea who is said to have gifted Jesus
his empty burial plot. Fascinating
stuff. And I say that because when I was
there the first time several years ago,
our tour guide told us that the church
of the holy supplr was built on an
ancient rock quarry. And rock quarry
sounds like the opposite of a garden.
So, how was it a
garden? Well, now I know. And now you
know. The Bible got it right. Now, if
you'd like to learn more about the land
of the Bible, but in a really fun way,
be sure to sign up for an Artza box.
Artsa comes up with a new theme every
few months. They gather products around
that theme from small businesses and
charities and places like Jerusalem and
Nazareth and Bethlehem. And then they
send everything to you in a box. Every
box comes with a booklet that connects
you to the land of the Bible. You'll
learn about history, geography, and
important archaeological sites. And
you'll even learn some Hebrew along the
way. But you'll also get spices, snacks,
crafts, decorations, soaps, jewelry, all
kinds of things straight from Israel and
produced by local artisans and farmers
who share their products with the world
through Artza. Artza boxes are not
expensive. They're fun to open with your
family and they make awesome gifts. If
you'd like to start getting your arts
boxes, the link is in the description.
Be sure to use the promo code dizzle to
get a discount and to let them know who
sent you.
[Music]